Tuesday morning Chicago bunch of
meetings and then flying home heading to
London tomorrow first thing in the
morning wasn't done businessman life
hashtag matches
[Music]
first wine club is going out that's
super fun Ryan did you order the white
club what the [ __ ] that's just I was
supposed to and you what happened was
you're not really my friend you don't
care about me or you're drinking wine at
a better price point than you are
normally you know it's $55 a month and
shipping and we're included one two
three or four bottles a month and next
month
it's me four bottles all built for your
Thanksgiving do you have Tyler to email
me almost gonna send it to Marcus old
dear Tyler please cancel Ryan's
subscription about two Rozier's that are
big time rose days I think people think
about Rosie just in the spring in the
summer but big time compliment with like
an aperitif for a lot of the stuff that
people drink at Thanksgiving so I'm
gonna pink up people's turkeys morning
Instagram over here thank you so much so
you're with us the whole time it's great
so just did the bags good morning
Instagram good to see you everybody's
doing super well I'm gonna talk about
competition entrepreneurship and so the
exciting part is either the wine is free
or the conference is free at my original
stomping grounds first 200 people that's
it locking it down 8 a.m. to 10 a.m.
Saturday October 14th of Springfield New
Jersey
great meetings at PepsiCo Chicago now
heading out to your client stuff or pure
[Music]
but now what you're watching is
innovation innovation innovation
features futures features today's poll
feature is a super intriguing to me
because it's now starting to make a
story's function more interactive more
data collection more valuable Iran keeps
getting kicked out because it enough
spot
[Music]
what are you filming it wasn't filming
are you filming now you guys missed it
d-roc was once again wrong and I was
once again right I didn't see it
honestly what are you talking about
you're right
Gary was shutting down pure wild
breaking news brand clothes brand
clothes
sure well fails on d-roc support
everybody here already loves the rock I
know you know like they all like him
more than me it's like that whole like
very happy with mott on Wine Library TV
to like that's just how it always is
like you're like the oh I like that guy
better you know I'm just better at
sucking
no I don't think so a general and D
Roxanne amazing dude he's pretty amazing
but he has shortcomings on episode 307
I'll expose them all right
let's talk about how this was our really
are hardcore trip yeah let's sum it up
for the vaynernation here on dailyvee
like this was what we interesting what
was most amazing about me so this is the
first trip that me and Gary have taken
that's pur Lisse pur well-focused yeah
so this was solely pure well focused and
it was super interesting cuz he had his
gallery pure wow hat on
you know I think I'm a good salesperson
this was fascinating for me I saw a
different type of seller and he makes
magic in the room it's pretty it's
pretty unique he truly is a very good
marketer he thinks of things on the spot
when he hears a bit of information from
people he's able to really synthesize
the room and he Rock you know that and
just spit it out in a very unique way
and you know I think there's a lot of
people that are really good at that but
super creative super creator that's good
that's the surprising part right no not
really I feel like you know what it was
I knew that you'd be creative I mean you
don't get to where you get without being
creative and being able to sell but it
was interesting to see you do it in my
world as opposed to your wall right to
be able to be a chameleon and doing
different businesses is really really
unique we should Brian on the show more
often so come on no no back where we
kindling the brand Vader X brings back
here well on a serious note I think
instead of just like a puff piece for me
and propaganda for me let's turn this
into you guys
the chameleon part empathy the other
person it all works out the reason I'm a
good speaker like it's about the other
person I'm grounded as a businessman I'm
a good businessman I really know how to
run business so when the when I'm in
these rooms I'm empathetic to what
they're trying to achieve whether sell
product they'll brand its I can audit
very quickly I'm fast that's why I'm
great at QA so in that room in about two
seconds I understand through business
it's like just true and so to me the
reason so much is working for me as I am
religious about the end consumer and in
a b2b environment that means their
business and in the speech that means
the people in the audience and when I
create products like the wine club or
for DS or all these different things
it's always about the other person and
the leverage is when you're more
valuable to the other person than they
are to you
the end yeah you know it's shocking I
used to think good businessmen always
found a way to you know win a deal or to
figure out the better end and something
that Gary does she shockingly often is
make sure that he loses deals he makes
sure that the other person feels like
they're getting the better end of the
deal
that they feel like not that only that
they think they're getting the better
end but they are getting the better end
of the deal so that in six months from
now when he really needs to he can come
back and he can ask for a favor
accordingly but it's really honestly a
very serious note because you haven't
felt it full circle or not right 90
always would just be always in the place
where you have the leverage yeah like it
might like if I get hit by a truck and
my brains not as good and I'm not good
anymore number like I tear off of that
hey can you find it can you help me I
don't have it anymore but like that's
the beauty of being a business person
not an athlete you know you get
exponentially better or not slower and
not as good well it's about the other
person man run the marathon not the
sprint the short deal where you got the
extra so much the flow of so many of you
you're looking for in a short term
everybody pounding me Gary do this for
me do this for me how about do something
through that's howdy ruckus in that seat
it's true i way overpaid for pure Wow
but a much better deal overpaid overpaid
now
[Music]
fast test alert
dude it's the same old [ __ ] 307 Foods in
you still don't know
better wake the [ __ ] up
[Music]
hey guys I interrupt this vlog to make
this important announcement a lot of you
have a whole lot of excuses not being
able to produce content you know don't
have designers don't have this don't
have money here is a post that I posted
on Instagram that's doing super well and
it is basically the screenshot of one of
my tweets that was all written words so
stop [ __ ] making excuses and start
doing period guys quick quick a question
of the day in the blog little new new
feature here derive so excited what is
holding you back from making more
snapchat contents lurkers answer so many
of you watching this for free I'm asking
for nothing in return and you can't even
give me a content you dirty dirty
lurkers come out come out come out come
out and answer this one today what is
holding you back from creating more
snapchat content
[Music]
and there with that oh crap I do call
for call anyway